[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits
the podcast where two lifelong friends
talk about life for a long time
i'm rhett and i'm link this week at the
round table of dim lighting
we are talking about your first kiss
stories
and ours as well we're gonna get all
those because
this is our first episode back from
from taking a three week 20 20 break a
three week break
we took a twee week break and speaking
of first
right at the top boy if it sounded a
little weird you
you added a little something it was
different i did because we
we've discussed it not as much as i
would be comfortable
not as much as i needed to be
comfortable enough uh you know
i'm i'm very proud of you that we were
just like going for it we remembered
we decided to put the slogan that new
slogan at the time well we actually
talked about this like a year ago that
we were going to
try to find a way to encapsulate what
this podcast is so anybody who happens
to be
tuning in for the first time would
understand what it is right from the top
yeah but it's hard to know
it's when you're doing it and you've
done this podcast for so long and
and and you've done it in different ways
and i also have done it
it's kind of hard to know you're real
close to it and we do we talk about so
many things and
have tried so many things that it's hard
to say well this is what this podcast is
but
that's what we've landed on maybe it
will help you
as you tell people about this podcast
that you that you enjoy listening to
to lifelong friend nope not lifelong two
yeah
yep not best friends though two lifelong
best friends
we are best friends we are but my vote
was to not include it in this just
because
sounds like a better slogan talking
about life for a long time
the podcast where two lifelong friends
talk about life for a long time
not a really long time because just a
long time but
and by a long time we mean just like
podcasting like an hour
so it's not really a long time well if
you okay if you
were told you need to go talk to this
person and
then and then you were like well how
long and somebody said an hour
that's a long time but but if you said
you need to listen to this podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time you're like whoa
it's a podcast where they talk for a
long time so you're talking like three
hours
no you're thinking you're taking the
long
and applying it to signifier and
applying it across all podcasts i'm just
talking about
normal conversation standard
conversational podcast is an hour-ish
and the most popular podcast in the
world by the way
is like three hours on average
yeah so that this isn't a lo an hour's
not a long time
so here so that so that's good and what
i'm saying is it's good it's it's
good it's kind of like leading with a
negative it's like they talk for a long
time
you'll have to get used to that no it's
just an hour oh that's just a podcast
this is why
i'm glad we didn't have to discuss it
because this is what the discussion
would have been and then you would have
lost heart
but i but i and you would have gotten
frustrated but i love the fact that
you you gave in and we just said it i
haven't given in
it can change welcome to ear biscuits
where two lifelong best friends you can
talk about
life for an hour so i
i don't have any problem you keep adding
best and you are my best friend and we
are
changing the second part too i'm not
practicing what you told me i'm
iterating
okay but that doesn't happen welcome to
earbuds there's no wordplay in that the
podcast where
two lifelong friends discuss
talk about not discuss discuss is a
little too self-important
it's like oh these are important topics
and we're going to we're going to turn
them over and we're going to come to
conclusions no we're just talking
right i never said discussion you added
that yeah
and i was and you know you've also taken
out life for a long time
which is kind of the only reason i liked
the lifelong what i came up with
the podcast where two life-long friends
talk about
life for a long time yeah you do you
like it you do like it
i was kind of searching for it but yeah
but it but you found it because it's
natural i need to just go for a drive
and say it
about 80 times is that how you do things
so what if it is but like there's so
much else in life
here's your experience but when you
can't no it's just that's how i
internalize something that would have to
you have to say the same way a lot
here's a you underestimate you came up
with this catchy phrase and it made
sense in your mind but then it has to
i have to transfer it to my mind
if i had to come up with it you would
have to make sense of it in your own
mind come
you'd have to come to terms with it i
don't think it's a lot it makes sense
and if
that required you driving and talking to
yourself it would
i wouldn't ridicule you i think it would
have required you telling it to me and
then i would have been like
that's good can we start over but me
say that part you say the other part
yeah yeah i'll give you i will buy your
lunch
if you get it right if you get it
exactly right on the first time i will
buy your lunch
what can i pick what it is too yeah
okay even if it's something oh that's
that's not very healthy
even if it's unhealthy i don't believe
you're gonna get it right
okay here we go welcome to ear biscuits
the podcast where two lifelong friends
discuss
i knew it i knew it welcome to ear
biscuits where two lifelong friends talk
about life for a long time that was it
if you consider 60 minutes or so a long
time you don't get your lunch now
i get a lot i'm so shiny i'll just pay
for it
let me get it i'm gonna get i'm gonna
the second part of this is
fine go get a tissue we had to cut the
ac off because again we're not
in our studio well we haven't said that
i also said this week at the round table
of dim lighting and um
i don't know if it sounds a little
different but if you're watching this
it does look different because we're not
at the round table of dim lighting
that's the other thing
this is another first we are in our
creative house now this is
um you know this is we got everything
set up we even got the sign here
this is not a permanent move by the way
we're going back to the round table of
demo
waiting but what i mean what if i don't
it could be it could be but so far i
don't like it it's a move of out of
necessity uh there's construction going
on
at the studio right now including in the
ear biscuits room
and so we have moved things over but we
didn't want it like we actually took
some
time so that it would be a better
experience we we we're not using our usb
mics we're like using
the actual setup that we typically use
and we did bring the sign light link set
and there's some sound proofing so
hopefully it doesn't sound so echoey in
here
but we're a little close to each other
we're a little closer and and the
lighting is not dim
like i could immediately knock both of
your eyes out this is
not the round table of dim lighting it
is a round table though
we talked about bringing the round table
and then they tried to disassemble it
and they realized somebody had glued it
together yeah it was it it
cannot come out of the room without
being destroyed well
you could probably just yeah if you just
cut the legs off and then or like
re-fasten them yeah re-glue them yeah
so here we are we we're we've already
experienced
two big firsts a new catchphrase
explanation at the top of the episode
and being here for the first time that's
just by way of summary
now we can move forward um i think
that's wha
we decided to talk about first kisses
because
we were talking about it being the first
episode back from our break
and uh we do have some stories from you
of your first kisses
and we'll get in all that in a little
bit but
um wasn't much of a break i mean
it's not really our first it's usually
when we take a break and we come back we
have so much to update each
other on well and it's also less than
like
it was a three-week break for you the
listener but it's
less than three weeks since we recorded
the last podcast
of the of the last season so but i i
think it's a
yes there's no nothing is happening this
is the feeling
of of covid life
yeah you're looking for something to be
new summer
and even when you think things are gonna
be new especially in california it's
like oh we got pull you got to pull it
back and i i agree with the pullback
yeah but um it's it's just
disheartening well i think there's
something happened
when summer rolled around i mean first
of all everybody had this secret hope
that the virus would go away during the
summer right and
and and there was some even though
scientists were saying that that
probably wouldn't happen
there's some reason to believe that
viruses wouldn't be as serious during
the summer but it turns out that doesn't
have any effect on the
coronavirus so but just the fact that
even when you live in california and
it's not like there's a real big
seasonal change but
life is different during the summer
right the kids are out of school
and you you go on vacation you travel we
were planning on going back to north
carolina during
july and seeing our families and that's
not happening
um and our kids were already out of
school
and they're still just out of school so
they're at home and you see the same
people
all the time i remember yeah i mean
i'm trying to figure out
i'm at a different place now i i
remember when we hit day 50 and i think
it was
in a vlog i don't know if it made the
edit but i was like
50 days in quarantine
and my you know i no longer count i no
longer have any interest
in knowing how many days it's been
because
i mean we haven't we've been very uh
conservative in terms of like sustained
staying quarantined and so even as
something's loosened up
that not for us i mean we don't even
and i'm this is not to judge anyone but
this is just
in an effort to keep our crew safe when
we get together and shoot but like
we don't even go to the grocery store
like we don't go in any place i
i the only place i've been indoors
with the exception for like maybe three
minutes at a bike shop that was had two
people inside of it
other than my house that's it i don't we
don't go inside we get our groceries
delivered
or we pick them up curbside yeah um
it's just more of the same yeah and
i no longer count i mean are you
counting can you i did not
count originally so i wouldn't know
where to start
yeah because 50 days i was like 50 days
what a huge deal we were talking about
this earlier
but there and i'm not an i'm not a
routine oriented person right i don't
like to do the same thing every day
but something about us not traveling
and not doing much besides shooting
gmm shooting this show coming to the
creative house and do and doing the
stuff that we're doing like on tick tock
or the social media stuff
it's made my mornings way more
predictable
right and so i'm not going to the gym
i'm working out in my garage
i'm i'm doing my back stuff
my exercises my meditation
and i've never done those like and you
get the little alerts on your app that
say that like
it's time to meditate or 10 days in a
row you know or
20 days in a row yeah i think i got to
like 30 days in a row at one point
skipped a day had to start over but i've
never
been that consistent with any of those
things and there's and i
even though i'm stir crazy
there's something about getting into
that rhythm of like exercising and
meditating
and actually like having time for
reflection and like journaling even
even journaling um i feel like i'm in a
pretty good place
yeah that makes me angry because
at myself not at you because
the opposite happened with me like right
at the beginning
and i talked about this i was like you
know i'm just i'm buckling down on
routine
because i always love routine you know
it's like i now have opportunity to do
more of the things i want to do
incorporating my routine every day i can
work out
and meditate on the same day whereas
before
i just have i would have to alternate or
something like that
and i went uh i think it was
50 days in a row meditating because the
app kept up with that
that and that's a lot and then after
that
it says your record was that and now
you've done two days in a row
yeah yeah you gotta work back up to it
i've never done more than four days in a
row
since since i broke the streak of 50.
and i was working out
and i stopped doing that i just got out
of that
because my my shoulders started hurting
again and it and i got discouraged
and then it's like oh you sleep a little
bit later you know it's
and then you just get a little i get
down on myself about it
um so i'm still doing i i try to
and then i was like i'll just as long as
i just walk every day you know i gotta
you gotta keep doing something
right you know you got to stay active
and i did
and so i just shifted from working out
because my shoulder is just walking
and listening to a book and then i got
done with my book
and it started getting really hot really
early
yeah yeah yeah and it's very i mean now
i don't it's very hot in this room can i
just say that
i like it like what i worked out this
morning
so my internal temperature is it's
really high right now
yeah so you look at me you should you
shouldn't work out i'm like sweating you
just wake up a little bit later
phil don't feel don't feel as bad about
yourself i mean it's like
there's like a flirtation with the form
of depression here
i think it's because that's just the
natural
i mean when you're cooped up and it's
not that's not your way of life
it's difficult and that that's that's
the kind of
i was talking about this in therapy i
was like i
feel kind of um
i do feel a little guilty right because
the average person most people i know
are having a really difficult time and i
thought
oh man this is gonna be really difficult
for me because
i like things to be shaken up i like to
go places i like to go out i don't like
eating at home
you know what i'm saying but all i'm
doing is eating at home yeah
but to me it's a testament to the power
of exercise and meditation i don't know
which one is more
yeah but something about there is this
prophylactic effect of exercise
on your mental well-being exercise and
meditation
what you mean like a like like a condom
for your mind
um no but i what i'm saying is that
my experiences right now
the circumstances and i'm not saying i
haven't been down and i haven't had
days of depression and sort of just like
listlessness and just feeling like
i can't get motivated i mean there's
been a couple of times you know we're
working on a couple of things that
require some writing
and some days it'll be like oh
i i could do this all day and then some
days it'll be like i got
nothing for this which is kind of but
that's sort of typical anyway right you
don't ever you don't always have it
but i was talking to my therapist and
saying that there's just something
about i've never ever been this
consistent
with my like daily practice of
exercising meditation
and i'm experiencing the benefits of it
like and i
like i said i feel guilty but also i'm
reminded that
when things do get back to normal
because they will we will start going
into the office
we'll start traveling again we'll start
going to things that kind of shift your
schedule
around knock you out of your routine
getting home late from something like
i'm getting home late what is that like
i'm home every single night at this
i'm home already oh yeah you know and so
the idea of having that routine shaken
up and the amount and walking too i mean
like i'm doing a bunch of walking
and i didn't do any walking at all like
there's i'm seeing parts of the
neighborhood that i've never seen
and so i i have this like desire to like
okay how do you
how do i hold on to this because i feel
like if i can take this
practice into my normal busy life when
things get normal again
i'm gonna be better off but i i know i'm
not gonna be able to keep up with it
it's just it's just the fact that i have
the freedom to do it is the only reason
that i'm
being so consistent right now but if you
i mean it's it's so hard to process what
you're saying because
like it does make me
like i said it makes me feel angry or
just frustrated because
i just feel like it's hard to get what
once you're
if you're not in that place hearing
somebody say they're in that place
doesn't
encourage you to be in that place it
just at least for me it's like
well i i was like i would
be like well i did you know i think if i
started
working out and doing something more
consistently i think that would help me
but maybe i just need to say you know
it's okay to just not
not do that for a little while you know
and then when it is
because i have to be ready to
to launch back into something but i do
think i feel the cumulative
uh problems associated with not doing
that right you know and
because i do think it it spills into you
know you get so antsy with everything
else that we are not
able to do in the way we want to do it
yeah
you know um that's that and that's the
weird thing
the fact that we're not working on
something
that is taking us out of the office and
into meetings and you know what i'm
saying like that
people interaction that's like what i
live for
is the dynamic nature of our jobs right
i mean we we do
we have a lot that is the same over and
over again but we have a lot that makes
it very dynamic and it makes it
interesting and you're collaborating and
you're trying
new things and most of the things people
never see but we're working on things
and that's why i can only go back to
well what's hap it's oh it's because i'm
exercising every single day
it's like i'm not having time to let
those those thoughts
and those frustrations which under any
other circumstances
would make me feel down and make me feel
depressed
um so yeah to me it's just like okay i
gotta remember this i just gotta
remember it
ah yeah i don't know i'm sorry
i'll be better if i made you feel worse
but all but i'm just saying
hey you're speaking your truth it has is
separate from me
and i'm all i'm saying is that as
someone who
has thankfully not stopped
the these processes i think that's the
only thing keeping me together right now
i think it's the only because it's
definitely not my circumstances
yeah right and again there's i mean it's
like we've got
we don't have nearly as many worries as
a lot of people
oh yeah you know so it's uh let's
let's move on we're gonna talk about
kisses
first kisses but first we're gonna talk
about
uh mythical.com it's a website we
started a while back
lots of good stuff uh there's always
something to surprise you at
mythical.com
the the uh good mythical summer t-shirt
check that out this thing this thing
will make you happy
i think you know sometimes it's just
about putting on the right thing
deciding to get fully dressed and
just seem ready for life like brush your
teeth put on some clothes
and if you put on the right shirt even
though you may not be experiencing the
summer that you're used to
the good mythical summer t-shirt
might be that little extra thing that
you needed we're not doing it in tank
top this year right
tank the tank option i don't know i
could use a tank top right now like
there's some tank i'm feeling like
there's some tank there's some tank
options
that are gonna be so hot under my arms
right in the uh in the mythical store
there's tank options there's i think
that's in the works yeah
but i don't know if it's of this shirt i
can't i request one of those
you got some water skiing fish head
people yeah i mean that is just
fun mythical.com i feel better now
i feel totally better you thought about
selling t-shirts and that makes you feel
better
uh before we talk about kisses i do we
didn't talk about what's on your nose
is it noticeable i don't know if you can
see it on camera
but uh i mean i asked you about it and
you were like i'll tell you on the
podcast okay so i have to ask you is it
a
is it a scab it's a scratch because when
i got up
it was like a bloody it's uh when i got
up this morning it was a bloody
thing it looks like at the end of my
nose it just had a blood
test oh really it looks like you just
got scratched by a bobcat
uh last night uh was it a bobcat
no it was a tree i was throwing some
frisbee with my boys
we like to go out and throw some frisbee
you know in the street
in the street yeah and uh
lincoln threw the frisbee up in the tree
and
it was just high enough where if i
jumped
i could i think i could grab the frisbee
because i shook the limbs
in the lemon tree and it didn't fall and
that's not a euphemism you
actually have a lemon tree right and
then i was gonna
so then i was like i'll just i can jump
and i can grab it but what i didn't take
into account was
in between where i would jump and grab
it
there were a bunch of other limbs yeah
so when i jumped up
the lower limbs they called the lower
limbs that were right there
you know when you're focusing on
something things closer to you get out
of focus
just let this be a lesson so i just i
raised my hand and i just
it was like superman taking off like
like fist in the air
except that all of these limbs that were
apparently just inches from my face
before i started to jump
were not in your face where then i like
i jumped right into limbs i mean
it could have been worse thank god i
wear glasses right
you know i i'm constantly even
even if i had 20 20 vision without
glasses
i turns out i would need to wear them
just for like kurt ramsey
eye protection yeah i mean i could have
lost my eyesight last night
but instead i just it it hit my glasses
and it hit the end of my nose and i'm
like man that really hurt
and when i went inside there was like a
big bloody spot there on the end of my
nose
you know you it
don't there's a life lesson here
you know don't get so focused on the
frisbee that you lose sight of the limbs
right in front of your face
i think the live lesson is use a broom
get a broom
yeah that's why jump when you can get a
broom this morning
interesting that we had similar uh
situations
this morning uh i had to grab a suitcase
for my wife
uh which we keep stacked up on this
shelf in the garage
okay and uh because she is she's taking
a little
a little beach trip with the kids a
sabbatical from you
uh and then i am going to later will
join them
uh but
they should so it's it's up high and i
was like
i can't reach that i could potentially
jump to grab it
[Music]
but i'm 42. there are limbs in your face
i'm 42. i don't jump for things
you know so many things could go wrong
so i grabbed
a golf club because that was the thing
that was closest to me but i couldn't
get
either side neither the grip nor the
club head
underneath it under the handle because
the handle was one of those away
um suitcases and so they're like flush
until you pull on them you got a step
ladder yeah but that was on the other
side
of the garage and oh goodness i'm 42 you
can't walk across your garage
well mr still working out every day
can't walk over to a step ladder no no i
can
it's just i don't know if i should okay
but then i was like
shoot man i had i actually did think to
myself you've been working out you can
jump
you can jump up there and
uh thankfully there were no lower limbs
in the way
uh there was nothing but air between me
and the suit you jumped
i jumped and it was like first try
slipped my fingers right under the
handle
and beckoned the suitcase my way
and then when i came back down i i did
the smart thing i
released as i was coming back down so as
to leave it dislodged but not falling on
me
and then i was able to do a baby jump
grab it and pull it down it hit you in
the face no no no no facial injuries
no life lesson to be learned i guess no
i just got the suitcase
um you know i think what you described
is
not unlike a first kiss
you've gotta you gotta really work up
your gumption
you gotta you gotta convince yourself
that you think about it you can go for
it
and then you gotta you gotta reach up
and you gotta you gotta be
you to have a gentle sort of caress
well you should be gentle then you gotta
based on some of these stories that is
the case
the moment where you can really latch on
is when you should let go
and then didn't go for a second you're
delicate you're talking about a tease
no just you know there's there's there's
always
there's plenty of time for a second kiss
the first kiss should not try to be the
end-all be-all
that's virtually impossible now
we've done an episode i believe it was
episode 114
about first kiss stories and when we
decided to do this episode we were like
oh it's our first episode best fir
back first first first first kisses
let's do that and then we we didn't even
realize we had done an episode
right um this is not an uncommon issue
until
kiko pointed it out right because i
think subconsciously we're looking for
any chance to talk
and our wives support this assertion
to talk about our first kisses or our
first girlfriends or our second
girlfriends
like you know we always go back to them
um
but in that episode we did share our
first kiss stories i think we can
revisit them
a little bit if you haven't heard that
we'll give you the gist of it and maybe
have a different take on it
if you're really interested you can go
back and listen to that we we got a
couple of stories from
from listeners in there and then we had
a couple of crew members come on and
tell their stories but um
we got some we we got some some good
stuff from you guys
uh yeah so we'll we'll keep our um
recounting our stories relatively short
since we've told them before and we've
actually told them
outside of the podcast as well but the
update on my
story is that you actually had the
the privilege of being with me when we
visited
the location of my first kiss during our
trip back to bowie's creek
and we i invited you to reenact it with
me
and then we showed that on well you made
me hold your hand and then
i i mean there was no kissing right
that's true
but i wasn't comfortable i wasn't
comfortable with getting close to that
yeah i could tell uh it was at the is
that the fountain
so that videos on on an episode of ltat
that
that uh aired after our buoys creek
documentary episodes from i guess last
year but i'm going to give you a little
background that i'm not sure i've given
before
uh and of course i i had begun dating
or going with is what we called it at
the time amber
and i knew that tonight was the night
i don't know how long we've been going
out but it was like you know you start
going with somebody and you start
kissing them this is the
the order of things well the order of
things is that i date amber
and kiss her first right she's my first
kiss
and then you date her after me and she
becomes your first kiss
did you actually date her yeah for how
long but you
did you did you you just kissed her that
time and then probably didn't kiss
her again am i okay some uh right or
wrong
i i can't imagine that you kissed her
again i don't know that would be very
surprising to me
i don't remember because that was
seventh grade
yeah it was seventh grade uh
i don't think i kissed her again i did
um do you want to tell your story first
it was that
it was at a birthday party at the
lilington
routine building and there was like a
big
open dance floor what is a ruriton
nobody was dancing
i don't know it's it's it's it's people
who is it like they broke
they broke off from the puritans it's
like yeah we're not quite as pure as the
puritans or maybe they ruined the
puritans yeah i think i think they
decimated they decimated the puritans
they uh they tainted the puritans we
rorantened
so them like a place of debauchery which
is interesting is what is why you kissed
there we were
we were we were sitting beside each
other shoulder to shoulder in these like
folding chairs and they were like on the
edge of
a dance floor that nobody was dancing on
and uh
the best michael and anna were sitting
next to us and
basically they
they sent me the message that i was
supposed to kiss amber this was the time
you know amber wanted me to kiss her but
like we didn't communicate about this
it was just michael looking over at me
and saying
go for it yeah um
yeah so i went in for the kiss and and
the story goes that he
you know he timed it uh i can't remember
how many seconds it was i can't remember
what i said how many seconds it was you
have to go back and
listen to the three years ago when i
told this story
but michael timed it yeah
and it was it i mean it was it was
multiple seconds
like i'm gonna say either seven nine or
14
i don't know what i said before and i
would and i'm gonna
i was more reliable in telling the story
than i am now
because i haven't thought about it
probably much since we need to connect
with michael
because um
michael plays a a pivotal role in in my
story as well
because i mean not only was he there
with
it wouldn't have been with anna in
eighth grade that would have been you or
what would it would have been that was
me
yeah he was with ann in seventh grade
who was he with
that night anna no who was he with the
eighth grade
uh night who was he with
i don't know he was always with somebody
that's always with somebody he and he
had
he had confidence the thing the thing
for me when i revisit the story was that
i did it because i i felt like i should
do it like i
i wasn't i didn't have this i didn't
have a i didn't have a sex drive
at the time i didn't i mean i was a late
bloomer
it it it came later i guess no pun
intended
but it was like you know i got it you
felt pressure you thought
yeah i mean it was literally like you
need to you need to
you felt external pressure i felt
internal pressure like a
geyser like a literal geyser and it was
you know it was a long i remember she
was on my right so i had to
you know i had to go over and my head
tilted to the left
and it was a i mean it was a french kiss
it was like okay there's
you know as i've said many times
i i was like i gotta be ready for this i
had practiced on my bed post
i it might be a little odd that that
same bed is still in our house and lando
sleeps in it but it is painted have you
told him that
no have you showed him which post it was
son come here let me show you something
it was a round post
and i don't i don't a very face like but
it was but it was like a head
like it was like making out with a
shrunken hair yeah her head was at least
four times the size of that bed post
uh so that was probably difficult to
navigate and it was um
it was uh it was just a wood veneer it
was a wood stain
it had no mouth but it wasn't white
paint like it is now it's not nearly as
kissable
and also the wall in my shower
and th this is this is so interesting
this is come on i never
practiced this has come up in
conversation recently because of that
tick tock where i made out with myself
in the mirror
yeah and it was i mean it definitely
brought back that memory of
me making out with my bed post did you
learn anything i just don't think i
would love to learn
the shower is better because it's wet i
mean it's too wet but at least you know
hey
in a really wet kiss situation i can
still find my way
i just i don't know why it never crossed
my mind that i needed to
practice because i would have walked
because you were so driven
and motivated to to make out
with your girlfriend that like you'd
think that you would but to me it was
the pressure of like
i got to know how to do this i got i'm
supposed to do this right now and yeah i
wasn't thinking about
anything other than i felt like i was
about to pull back
the curtains on the most amazing thing i
will ever experience
it was just all anxiety for me and it's
like you know it was it actually wasn't
bad my recollection of it was that the
kiss
wasn't wasn't bad i mean it wasn't
amber's first kiss
and um she she helped me out
she did a she
she she she carried her weight and more
and there was a there was a there was a
clockwise
motion to the to the tongue situation
there was like a there was like a
circular dance happening in there and i
was like oh this is okay
this is what we're doing yeah you know
because
i mean there was no internet you
couldn't be searching for how to kiss
how to french kiss and i didn't have any
there was no one i would talk about it
with like
but there were movies i think i just
went off movies
but even that you're i mean you're not
inside of the mouth you don't know
exactly what's happening you can talk
you can tell you can tell there's some
tongue exploration going on whenever i
looked at that i'd be
i was always just too embarrassed to
study it and of course i didn't watch a
lot of movies i didn't watch all those
make out
that's why you had to practice with your
shower because you didn't watch movies i
i that is a fact there's a lot i'm
learning right now so it was
it was the kiss itself was not a bad
experience but like
everybody was watching for me for
someone to be so anxious about it and to
feel like oh i got to do it and then
it's like hey
the entire party felt like was watching
you know it wasn't even dark it was just
yeah that's when you're dimly lit
given all the circumstances i think it
did pretty pretty damn well
i mean amber didn't dump me immediately
she didn't dump me because i was a bad
kisser
she dumped me because i was just a ball
of nerves probably and
i actually wasn't into dating as a
seventh grader right
it was just too early for me you know
right well my experience is a little
different i'm in my own head
my experience was a little different i
was
it was dark there was a fountain no one
was watching
because you took her out there i had not
practiced i had on my blue nike
sweatshirt
i knew i looked like a million bucks and
now i smelled good
this is this is before there was such a
thing as axe body spray
but there was deodorant
right guard okay probably put a little
on my neck
that is like a little blue residue that
was cologne or a little white rice that
was a cologne in 1991 it was like i'm
gonna put a little bit on my neck
i mean we were watching the movies with
our girlfriends
and then you asked amber to go outside
all of a sudden you and amber just leave
i knew it and take a walk and we're like
okay this is where see you later this is
where michael jubie i'm gonna i'm going
first name last name
now this is where michael jubie comes
into play
i've got a theory about michael jupi
okay
um does it involve his dad no okay mine
does but go ahead
oh i let's go ahead i know i know what
you're going to say you're going to say
that his dad taught him everything and
taught him how to have confidence which
that's true
yeah i have a much more complex theory
than that okay okay
you ever think to yourself sometimes the
simpler theories
are the more elegant you ever think to
yourself
man if i could go back to high school
middle school whatever like with the
current mind
that i have and mentality right
absolutely you think about how you would
navigate things so differently yes
and so especially i mean yeah with this
whole ball of nerve situation
yeah well yeah especially in your case
but i actually think the same thing
i mean i think about things like man
sometimes i wish i could just go back
even just the way i approached playing
basketball sure
like why did i was so stupid about the
way i approached it in so many ways but
anyway
um i believe that michael
was an adult who wished he was given
three wishes
as an adult you think he did go back to
go back and live his life over with an
adult mind
because if you think if you think about
it that's right every conversation you
ever had with him
every choice that he made like man
you're right he's like
you're mature this dude is playing this
game of life like it's a game and like
he knows
how to win it yeah yeah it's like he
doesn't seem he's not intimidated by
stuff
and he was a year younger than us
because he had skipped a grade
in his when he came back as an adult he
decided
i'm also going to skip a great day
because i'm impatient he was he was a
year younger than us
yeah but yet he was navigating all these
things
and then telling us and what he told me
and in high school he was dating women
one i mean two years and three years
older than him yeah
he was dating the girls that every guy
in the school wanted today and he just
showed up
and was like well i'm gonna date them
now because i am an adult i have been
sent from the future
that is the only explanation oh my gosh
it works doesn't it that's right we need
to call it
because juby is such an i mean maybe
he's an alien that's an alien
made up it's not yes if i heard anybody
whose last name is juby j-u-b-y
yeah that's definitely a name he was
asked what do you want your name to be
juby he just it's like the only thing i
can think of when i take human farm
and travel in the past so he
he was an alien who lived a life and
then went back and relived it
or or he was given three wishes as an
adult
and he was like i only need one and all
of the above is
to go back with this mind and relive my
life
that's my theory uh and what michael
told me
he just was like you know
he's got to be relaxed and
you need you need to you need to make it
count and you need
and you need to literally count right
like he he wanted me to count
how long the kiss was so i could report
back yeah he counted for me
and because he wasn't there i lost heart
i guess at seven seconds but but you did
have this conversation with him yeah
and he also told me he told me
the things he had a connection to dunn
right because i think
his parents were like members of the
shakura country club or something and
there was like a connection to dunn
actually i think his mom was
she was teaching at triton right that's
right that was it and so dunn
was like the city right they had a movie
theater
which i also kissed amber at but
they had a chinese restaurant they had
an interstate right
it's the crack capital of the world i
think there was a crack problem
but he had this insight into what the
kids at dunn
middle school were doing and when he
told me what the kids at dumb middle
school were doing
yeah like sex in the hallways i just
realized that i was
way behind the curve you know what i'm
saying i mean there was things happening
there was things there's just
people were discovering things about
each other's bodies in ways that
us kids in bowie's creek didn't know was
even possible
so he when he told me these things i was
just like whoa okay
all right done done sounds like a lot
for me and i'm and i want it all
right i want it all but that sounds like
too much i'm glad i'm on bowie's creek
okay so when presented with the actual
opportunity
what it amounted to was a seven second
you know wet oh okay i'm gonna go with
nine for me
um and uh but there were many more
seconds after that literal
seconds not that night in fact that
night i kept it
no i think i did it again
i can't remember i had this it just
popped into my head i think i have a
memory
of being like first kiss had a second
kiss right after
yeah i think so regardless there were
more kisses
afterward and um
never went to dunn but uh accepted
you you visited you didn't go to school
and done is that what you
yeah right but what do you you like that
theory about michael jubie we got to
call him
i think we could i think we could get
him to admit it yeah
were you an alien and sent from the i
think it's all of it
alien alien seems unnecessary because
aliens need to be educated
this is a man who had already lived a
life he went back and
and did it yeah did it right so much
confidence
quiet confidence took us a while to get
to your stories
carrie green uh responded to our prompt
about first kisses i was at six flags
with a group of friends we ate some
greasy food then rode a crazy spinning
ride then
rode a ride called the cave a boy i
liked leaned over
and kissed me and then he immediately
threw up over the side of the car
we were riding in never lived that down
yeah that's that's a tough first kiss
traumatic yeah that's traumatic when
your first kiss makes the makes the guy
sick
or it could have been everything else
that you listed before that i believe it
was but
you know at the time that you're you're
taking that and you're applying it to
yourself
we have another vomit story breezy
cheesy underscore breezy
i was camping with my best friend's
family and her dad had recently
remarried
her new step-brother had been flirting
all day and then
suddenly lunges at me the sudden lunge
is not cool
no that's not cool and puts his tongue
so far down my throat that i promptly
gagged and threw up on it okay wasn't my
finest moment
okay you know i'm not a uh i'm not a
forensic scientist
this is an unusually long tongue and or
an unusually sensitive gag reflex well i
mean if the ti
i mean it might be the thought of
there's a tongue that's been thrust into
my mouth
by surprise so that could make you gag
even if it wasn't like
deep because i mean i can somebody get
their tongue
all the way back to a place where you
would you'd choke on it i mean maybe
like a gene simmons i mean maybe it was
this gene simmons
i think if you really do like the 90
degree angle on the mouth like the two
mouths are totally
you know opposed you could really like a
mouth-to-mouth situation and then you
really
and you're really wide like
that snake jaw that's the kind of thing
that requires the cooperation of two
people and
she doesn't seem like she was
cooperating uh
and yeah it's not i mean it's not cool
at all
when you don't want to take anybody by
surprise i mean if you're in
kindergarten you want to steal a kiss
under
you know i mean i think that there are
certain circumstances in which
you know i'm talking about the first
time you kiss somebody
there are circumstances in in which it's
obvious everything about the environment
and everything about the signals that
you're giving to each other and
everything that you're saying
to each other yeah it leads you to
believe that it is okay
if you're looking into each other's eyes
for a prolonged period of time
and you're having a conversation a
romantic conversation
there's ways to i but i do think that
i think that just
asking permission is is is the way to go
here
oh yeah what well and i think you did
that i did that with amber and it wasn't
because it was
taught i wasn't it wasn't because
consent was
a buzzword at the time i mean obviously
was in my mind i wasn't going to do
anything that she didn't want
um i think in my mind it was more i just
want her to be ready
like if it felt like it actually once
you ask
the question then you have to do it i
think is what was happening in my mind
is like can i kiss you
and when she says yes it's like well you
buddy you be it's easier to ask can i
kiss you than it is to just go in and
kiss somebody
that's what i was thinking but in a
roundabout way i actually ended up
asking for consent which i'm proud of um
i'm just it wasn't it wasn't a pure
motivation but i think that
that is the that is the clearest way
forward
is to ask um speaking of which
bym beth said i went to badminton club
in high school okay your club
all right your high school had a
badminton club
uh i went to the club with a boy i was
dating we were both really nervous to
have a first
kiss so we made a bet that whoever
lost the game had to make the first move
see this
this is taking communication and then
instead of making it awkward just owning
it and
having some fun with it i really like
this here's the thing about badminton
first of all the thing that you're
hitting is called a shuttle [ __ ] yeah so
everybody's horny it's already sexual um
and it's a co-ed sport it's already
you know and so it's the perfect recipe
and a lot of people think
and you're you're like inches from each
other's face the whole time
really no there's a net separating
i was thinking like do you are we
thinking about the same thing you were
joking
a lot of people think that all the
business that's happening is happening
with like the football team and the
cheerleaders
you know no no no it's the badminton
club it's the dream
it's the drama club it's the theater
kids
oh yeah that's where all the hanky-panky
is having oh yeah you know okay so to
finish this one and then the next
next one supports this uh she said he
lost the bad
match but afterward he spent 20 minutes
pacing up and down
saying he was nervous well okay that's
when
you know once you had once you had
talked about it
and you reach an agreement then it's
like you got it you just gotta go for it
you didn't
you can't be dancing around the ledge
you gotta jump off right so she said
that she just kissed him first well
because you'd already established that
that was what was gonna happen
but there's something about it you build
it you can build you should build it up
because that's fun but you don't want to
build it up so much that like you
you're you're paralyzed right
but but i want to dig into this theory a
little bit because i think i'm on to
something and now we're not we weren't
theater kids
we weren't drama kids or band kids i
said i'll read this one
big time uh sarah a mine was in high
school
he asked me to meet him in the band bro
you know what's going to happen in there
the stairs
towards the practice rooms he's gonna
show you his instrument
where he told me to close my eyes
because he had a surprise for me
okay uh the surprise was him kissing me
we're married with two kids now damn
that was fast okay
i mean i'm not gonna comment on i i'm
glad that you're married with kids now
i i and again i think this is a
different time i would not advise this
technique yeah i don't
i would not advise this technique now
yeah yeah i think you got you got to be
a little bit more open you can't say go
here and close your eyes
right go hide and close your eyes yeah
now
like okay to get back to this theory
though because again
there's this sort of cultural narrative
that you've got
these you got the jocks and
and they're doing these things and
people are looking up to them
but like they're just hanging out with
each other all day you know what i'm
saying like
it's like it's it's these places where
people are
mixing with each other and especially
when you get into drama in theater
and now you're actually like you know
you're revealing things about yourself
you're having to dig
deep into yourself and like access your
emotions
for the sake of the art that is just
you add hormones into that vulnerability
that is
i mean blowing on horns i mean yeah
yeah band is so sexy when you think
about it i mean
you think about what's happening people
are just taking these
instruments and putting them in their
mouths they're getting the reeds wet
you know what i'm saying yeah they're
they're good with the mouth they're
they're doing
they're doing dexterous things with
their fingers and their mouths at the
same time
i mean this is foreplay if there is
foreplay
and just saying and parents need to
need to think about this when you buy
that trumpet for your kid
you need to understand what's about to
happen
do you know how you play a trumpet
though
so if you put your lips up to someone
like you're playing a trumpet it would
just be like
mouth-farting into their mouth i really
think it's the woodwinds that are the
sexiest
yes because you have you got to put your
tongue out just a little bit and just
that kenny g thing yeah yeah yeah i mean
the saxophone
the reason the saxophone is the sexiest
instrument because
it's not because of the sound it's
because of the reed and all the things
that you can touch
i mean yeah yeah yeah it's a you could
spend a lifetime
exploring all the new ways to caress a
saxophone
while it's so complex whereas a trumpet
is just like
three three things in a
sound you know if you know how to work
those three buttons you can get some
magic now a trombone
is a little different in and out
yeah the trombone motion is the most
sexual of all the instrument motions
right you put your mouth on it and then
you get you go in and you pump
you pump yeah wow
you're not doing that on the football
field no you're just
catching a ball over and over again
and even if you just want to think about
a flute now you're not i'll think about
it
you're not getting it wet and you're not
you're not wrapping your lips around it
but you're delicately blowing across
the open still sexy oh yeah the
woodwinds i'm telling you the woodwinds
the drums what about the the what about
the bass drum
the guy who just sits back in the back
and just boom just hits that
someone'll make out with it don't feel
too sorry for the guy
[Laughter]
i mean he's the loudest one there if he
screws up everybody knows it immediately
hey but sports sports you get sweaty
i i love the fact that when we put out
this prompt that members of the mythical
kitchen
responded nicole responded and said
i have my first kiss at a park after my
first day of
sports summer camp okay sports can be
sexy i guess my mom found out and i
wasn't allowed to go to camp
anymore well and then right under this
trevor
also one of our members of the mythical
kids i call him an intern but
he's not he's not it's just um he
responds to nicole it was right after
watching napoleon dynamite we finished
the movie and she was like do you want
to kiss now
i love that you know i love a
i love a woman who's just like do you
want to kiss now because they'll be like
hold on you know what dude yes do you
feel like you need to
clarify the fact that this is made up
from trevor
this did not actually happen what do you
mean why
it's not made up i can see that
happening do you want to kiss now
like when a movie's over it's like well
you want to kiss now oh i thought that
because you had put it under here i
i thought that trevor was replying to
nicole's
seeing that he kissed nicole no he's
just trying to be trying to be funny but
he
he put his own story yeah that makes a
lot more sense
napoleon dynamite's a weird i mean at
that age when you're really wanting to
have your
to to really start kissing it doesn't
matter what movie it is it's just you
know
as long as it's a movie well do you
remember
um this was not my first kiss but it was
my first kiss with a particular girl
um you were there and it was during a
movie
uh you got to give me more information
during the movie it was uh what movie
the girlfriend that
your girlfriend was friends with
introduced me to
and then we went down to
her cousin's house or something
the three of us went down to meet her
okay for like the first time
yeah and the first night and it had all
it kind of been arranged
like okay you guys are going to be
interested in each other i know you and
i know you
and so it was kind of like our first i
still don't i i do remember
that night but i don't remember the
specifics yeah like
me and my girlfriend this is junior year
in high school like her best friend was
like oh
you know rhett needs rhett would be
great with her and then you guys started
did you start talking on the phone or
something but it was definitely an
arranged
i met her for the first time that night
in in my memory
i don't know of my memory yeah which is
correct
yeah my girlfriend set you up
with her best friend who lived two
states
south and we had to drive down there to
see her no no we didn't drive to georgia
we drove to like wilmington
because she was her cousin was in
wilmington
but what are you talking about and so
that night the first night you met you
were making out with her
yes uh i i work quickly
well i'm a professional but do you
remember
the movie that was not watching no
what movie was it helen hunt you talking
about the tornado movie twister twister
it was twisted we were watching twister
twister that's romantic
but i don't know i mean it didn't matter
what movie we were watching
i was like oh this is gonna happen at
some point but you know
for some reason and maybe it's just
because i'm a i'm a student of the
cinema
i uh i i wanted to kiss her so bad but i
was kind of
into twister and i was like once the
kissing starts
to yeah you kind of want to lose
[Laughter]
[Music]
bill paxton he was great in that yeah
and uh the the effects for the time the
effects were great so when did you kiss
her during the credits
oh during the credits that's good i
think that's best
so a similar situation to trevor the
movie's over do you want to kiss now
right well once napoleon dynamite starts
dancing it's a long dance but we had
done lots of
hand-holding and my arm was around her
um and again we just met uh but it was
like
everybody knew that it was you would hit
it off and you had you'd built it up it
wasn't the first time you had talked
i believe it was oh really i don't think
i talked to her on the phone she was
like
but then you date i mean you guys dated
for a year and a half a year and a half
yep really and she
long distance for a year and a half yeah
i would
i would you would just go down to
georgia and visit her or she would come
up and visit you and stay
with my girlfriend because they were
best friends
yep because she and they were best
friends because she had lived in bowie's
creek and then moved away
yeah i mean i like knew her when she was
i knew of her when she was a kid
you know when i was a kid yeah that long
long distance
we can do we can do a whole episode on
long distance relationships that that
that was a whole thing like driving to
see your girlfriend
but the i mean when you talk about the
bold moves
i mean troy wood he said
it was in the back seat of my
girlfriend's
parents car with her parents still in
the front seats
no way in hell would i
think about kissing a girl with the
parents in the front seat i mean
i just couldn't bear the thought of like
i don't know
i do that like you know i told you the
story of like holding
i think it was amber's hand at the
baseball game and then your mom's seeing
us and me being embarrassed
you know it's like i don't know why i
was so embarrassed
about like having a girlfriend didn't
want to admit that to my
to my family because i didn't like any
question
about that would just embarrass me even
more
i you know and i don't you know it's
just i try to talk to my kids about
you know whatever it is that is part of
development i just try to talk about it
in like a normal way because i really
don't want them to think that
i don't want to do anything to build up
things for them make them more anxious
i mean if they because my blood runs
through their veins i think i'm
going to only tell them so many things
sure i think kids are
kids are going to be but by not who they
are but by not talking about it
for me i think it's set up this thing
was like oh this is
it's a secret and when you're a little
kid and like if you're
if you're kissing then it's like
you kind of instinctively know it's like
oh we can't tell anybody about this or
like
nicole's mom's saying she can't go to
the go to
the the camp anymore because there's no
telling what you're gonna do or i don't
know what our reasons are but it's like
oh this is this is something to keep
secret
to be ashamed i never i never kissed a
girl
in the back seat of a car while her
parents were in the front seat
but i do remember the girl i was dating
my freshman year
in high school her parents were driving
us around and we were in the back seat
and we were holding we were holding
hands and then
when her parents got out and we went to
the grocery store
like walmart i remember this because you
told me walmart
they went in and you stayed in that car
and just made out and the in the windows
start [ __ ]
when you make out in a car the windows
fog up and so we had to like stop
open the open the door
and that this happened a few times and i
remember you telling me about this
reporting and i was like are you kidding
me they could come back at any moment
yeah what would you do if the if her
parents came back and saw you
making out with their daughter in the
car well
most of the time when you're in that
situation the person
who is the daughter or son of the family
that you're interacting with
they know the deal you know what i'm
saying it's just like she didn't say
like
my parents would kill me if they knew we
were kissing in the back seat
yeah obviously so she was comfortable
enough with their response to
my impression of her parents is that
they knew what was what was going on
but i do want to quickly talk about
there's an infamous
story uh we would not mention any names
okay but there is an infamous story of
somebody that we went to high school
with
and again this is probably just one of
those rumors that happens but it was a
rumor that we all thought was awesome
at the time he was a few years older
than us now this is the are you talking
about
we had a friend who had an older sister
is that the story you're talking about
no i'm talking about
um a guy who was
two or three years older than us maybe
he was a senior when we were a freshman
but the story goes is that
he was in the back seat with his
girlfriend while her parents were
driving and they completed the act
they had sex they had full sex oh gosh i
i don't even remember that story because
it was such a load of [ __ ]
uh he
and she according to my sources i don't
even know who you're talking confirmed
it
well when i tell you who it was later
when this podcast is over
and i tell you who the guy wasn't who
the girl was you might be like okay
maybe it did happen
i'm just saying it is it is one of those
things it's probably not true but if it
was true
it would be them who did it listen okay
now this is a different subject matter
if we're going to talk about first
we have to save like like losing your
virginity
like a different podcast we can talk
about that as a different
that's quite a teaser uh
sammy uh larber
tweeted i don't know why i put such a
pregnant pause in there i think it's
lobber
my first kiss was a lovely man who soon
after realized he preferred men to me
uh or may don't take it personally sammy
i would say he preferred men to
uh all women i guess is what you're
saying
i had driven us home from a party in my
parents driveway
next to my minivan he kissed me i wish i
could make the squeaky noise it made
he pulls back and he asks like blowing
on the trumpet
he pulls back and asks where do i put
the tongue
i think you know communication i'm a
huge fan of communication you know
where do i put the tongue well there's
only a few
well what do you do with the tongue it's
like again i didn't know
again it's like you thought you knew by
looking at movies but there's never any
it's not an
endoscopy there you're never inside of
the mouth you don't know for sure it's
like oh there's a
you can do a rotation motion i think
this is i think this is how our minds
work differently right when i think
about
when i thought about kissing as a 14
year old
it didn't strike me as there was a
correct way to do it like that the fact
that there's a correct way to do it
is not something that that's not the
first thing that pops into my mind about
much of anything right
it's more of that and it is there is an
opportunity
to do it just start doing it you'll
figure it out
is kind of the way that i approach it
and
there's some things you get into some
trouble with that right because there is
a right way to like
change a tire there's a right way to you
know there's a thing called dumb luck
well i think there's also a thing called
dumb confidence and i think that's what
you had
well instead of like thinking that i'll
just start kissing and it'll work itself
out no it's like i envy that no what i'm
saying is that you have
this is the point i'm making there's a
difference between changing a tire
and kissing right kissing is
like you're talking you're getting into
the like do i do the tongue like this
well sure do i do the tongue like this
also yes
do i do the time you can do the tongue
however you want because it's like an
art form it's not a mechanical
thing that has rules that somebody came
up with that you have to subscribe did
anybody but any but
it seems like you had a conversation
with michael jubie about this i'm sure i
did see i didn't have any conversation
with anybody about this because it was
taboo
well i understood that michael was an
adult from the future who had three
wishes granted and he was
he'd come back to visit us and i tapped
into his wisdom i mean if you're gonna
if you're gonna overthink it or just
think it through
you need to be with somebody that you
can feel comfortable talking about it
like hey these are the
these are the questions that i have
where do i put the tongue
you know and them not to laugh in your
face and in some kids
some kids have this that kind of
relationship with their parents some
kids have that kind of relationship with
other like with an older brother or
sister yeah
it doesn't always happen the same way
but i do think
sometimes it hap it doesn't happen at
all and that was my case right
and but if you hadn't been i mean and we
weren't talking about it we
like the interesting thing is that i was
i mean i wasn't gonna ask you for advice
and you weren't gonna ask me because we
didn't know
we're gonna ask michael jupite but i
didn't ask him that and when you would i
mean by the time we were in high school
and like
i knew how to make out you know by that
point but when you were telling me
freshman year that you were in the back
seat in the walmart parking lot making
out in broad daylight
was it daylight yeah it was daylight
like 2 00
2 pm wow
i was just like man that's just but
that's far out man
[Laughter]
but don't you wish you could go back oh
yeah as an adult man oh yeah
i mean that sounds
horrible that's not what i meant do you
wish you could go back
with the mentality and
and and i try to i try to and i'm not
just talking about so you could kiss
people that's i'm just saying that
show that enjoy not be critical you
could not be crippled
by and i you know you were crippled by
anxieties about
am i doing things right i had my own
anxieties about like the pressure to
perform
and like i have to do this and i have to
follow these rules
i have to i have to be the best at this
and this and this in order to
receive love it's like if i could go
back and realize like no no no
you don't you don't have to play by
those rules like
yeah that's that's the thing i didn't
follow my heart i followed the rules
yeah and i definitely followed and and
you know if you
if you just follow but you followed your
heart a lot too
you know you were driven i don't know if
it was your heart maybe it was your
wiener
um well yeah it was in in certain
circumstances i
i wouldn't say rules weren't you had to
impose the rules over it but like i
couldn't get it i'd
the rules were so firm i just think the
rules were different from me like i
i but i was following the rules i i but
my
rules were you are very frustrated you
have to
you have to do these things
well in order to be
worthy of love i think is is and i think
that you thought
you have to do these things correctly
in order to be worthy of love yeah and
so
again it goes back to the the oneness
and the threeness
of our enneagram numbers um
but so when i guess when you when you
look back on it
i was i was using i was super motivated
and did a lot of things and
and i did enjoy i did enjoy myself i had
i i had a lot of fun
you did a lot of things you want to list
them out um well no i'm just saying that
like
i took that that that drive
and i applied it and i kept trying to
find the next thing oh so i wasn't
paralyzed i
was actually super driven to do things
but i wasn't
finding the love that i was seeking by
doing those things
but i was doing a lot of things but when
it came to
kissing i wasn't it was
it was pure i wasn't trying to
accomplish anything other than
i was like this seems like the reason
i'm here you know it's like yeah this
seems
like the most amazing thing that there
is in life is how
i thought about it as a teenager and so
i was like
okay i need to put myself into
circumstances where i can do this
i was preoccupied with it for sure i
think even when i
enjoyed making out with my girlfriends
it was there was there was just a lot of
other baggage that complicated it so it
was never like
oh this is this is a pure form of
enjoyment i mean i felt guilty as hell
the whole time oh yeah
so that complicated it um
it kept me out of trouble i'm sure but
just my
my uh you know very evangelical world
view at the time
which again was it was a for somebody
like me with my mentality
was also a prophylactic right
you know because it prevented me from
just being completely led by that
mentality
um but
i still enjoyed it it's just you know
you feel guilty after the fact strange
times
you know i think it but just to go back
to like
just the the sweet purity of a first
kiss
you know let's go back to that i think
it's
just um
it can be sweet right
and i think it yeah so i think if i
would do it again it would be
it would be much sweeter it wouldn't be
in front of everybody
yeah yeah i think you know that's why
hey let's step outside i mean later
behind the oasis you know like the the
the campbell university student center
like in between the dumpsters
you know i think that was the first
place anna and i kissed my so
like my in between the dumpsters my
third girlfriend it's like boy
good spot it really stinks at a dumpster
it's not a great place to make out but
no one's going to show up
but yeah not many people are going to
show up
better yeah the interesting thing is
again
like when i talked about the whole
asking can i kiss you it wasn't because
i was like
being super considerate it it was more
just like
this seems like what i'm going to do
right now but
the circumstances of the kiss
it was at night i had planned on it
she knew that it was gonna happen yeah
it was somewhat romantic
it wasn't too extreme that was a
fountain there was a fountain
i asked permission all those things i
actually feel like
okay that's how i i'm i'm i'm it's one
of those no i look back and i'm like i
don't have any regrets about that
i don't have any regrets about my first
kiss it's a good story
i'm happy with how it turned out i'm
happy with how this conversation turned
out
do you have a uh recommendation we gotta
get back into that it's your turn
i do um my family and i recently watched
a movie that i think has been out for
i may be out for two years but if you're
like me you did not see it originally
and that is uh it's a beautiful day in
the neighborhood the
mr rogers story with tom hanks playing
mr rogers i keep
waiting for the right time to watch it
and uh i know i'm gonna cry
what a wonderful movie what and what a
wonderful movie to watch with your
family
well yeah uh we watched it as a family
and everyone was crying
by the end of it which that doesn't
always happen to all
four of us i mean it doesn't take
anything to make me cry in a movie but
did you decide
hey we're gonna watch this movie tonight
and we're gonna cry did you did they
know it was coming too
or no i mean we knew that it would be a
sweet movie
it was it's not always easy to get my
boys to watch a movie like
it's a beautiful day in the neighborhood
but i saw an opening
and uh i was like no one's gonna die in
this movie
so prepare yourself to be disappointed
um
and uh you know there's no explosions
but it's just i mean
you already you already know because i
think you watch the the documentary
about
mr rogers just how significant of a life
he lived and all the things that he
stood for but
the way that they captured it in a
narrative form
and tom hanks is great of course but
just the the format the way that they
decided to format it and tell the story
was just very compelling
okay just watch it i have to highly
highly recommend it do you think
like at some point during the movie
christy and i can just start making out
i'll wait until the credits okay but the
credits if i remember correctly are
actually
pretty cool uh and you'll be in an
emotional state where kissing is
probably not on your mind so
okay maybe just just you take twister do
twister watch twister
do make it a double feature watch
twister first
okay make out make out in front of my
children and then start
it's a beautiful day in the neighborhood
and then
you won't want to kiss anybody just want
to hug everyone
hashtag gear biscuits let us know your
first kiss story or how you processed
any of this uh let's keep the
conversation going and let's keep this
going no more breaks
in the near future well i mean i mean at
some point there will be in the near
future
right but where are we going to be with
you every week same time same place
uh maybe not maybe this place for a
while
we'll see how things turn out to watch
more ear biscuits click on the playlist
on the right
to watch the previous episode of your
biscuits click on the playlist to the
left and don't forget to click on the
circular icon to subscribe
if you prefer to listen to this podcast
it's available on all your favorite
podcast platforms
thanks for being your mythical best